the city is home port to half a dozen
professional teams including one time
national champion miss Elam plus team
Elam is a family affair fathers fan and
Sons Eric and Tom race their boat miss
eel and the brothers design and build
boats in their own shop hydroplanes like
miss Elam are lightning fast because
they are designed to fly through the air
barely touching the water for a Seattle
boy racing line is a dream come true
growing up in Seattle hydroplane racing
was everything when you were kids here
and then unlimited hydroplane racing was
the pinnacle of motor sports in Seattle
but you know as a kid of my age I don't
know anybody that wouldn't want to run
unlimited hydroplane it's just it's
awesome the team's philosophy is simple
I'd like to say winning isn't everything
but I got to tell you winning is
everything and that's that's what drives
everything it's just a pure will to want
to win okay all right there now it's
like the boom all the way in second
place is the first guy to lose a key to
the team's success driver de Ville walk
one of the most successful racers in the
sport the motorsport today it's all
about relationships and communicating
the team that can communicate together
and keep about running you know under
adversity as a team that's gonna win in
the end team e lam is fighting for the
top spot in the standings and is busy
preparing for its next race
this week's problem the engine the most
critical component of the boat miss Elam
uses chinook helicopter engines to reach
speeds of over 200 miles per hour each
engine costs 125 thousand dollars and
can take ten weeks to adapt from
helicopter to hydroplane because of the
wear and tear of racing the team must
have more than one engine ready at all
times with the next race just days away
team alam is down one engine and
scrambling probably no one has really
had a good night's sleep in about three
weeks we have been working around the
clock we've been working to just just to
the point to get a few hours of sleep